étranger
[Musique]
[Musique] [Musique]
étranger [Musique] [
Musique] les
personnes trans ont leur place ici nous avons besoin des
personnes trans nous aimons les personnes trans les personnes trans ont leur place ici nous avons besoin des personnes trans nous aimons les
personnes trans les personnes trans appartiennent ici nous avons
besoin des personnes trans nous  aimer les personnes trans les personnes
trans appartiennent ici nous avons besoin des
personnes trans nous aimons les personnes trans les personnes trans
appartiennent ici nous avons besoin des personnes trans nous avons besoin des personnes trans nous aimons les personnes trans les personnes trans appartiennent ici nous avons besoin des personnes
trans nous aimons les personnes trans les
personnes trans appartiennent ici nous avons besoin des trans
les gens que nous aimons les gens trans les gens trans ont
leur place ici tu comptes
tu comptes et je me bats pour toi
et je n'arrêterai pas
[Musique]
étrangère